foreign
[Music]
well welcome to session 22 of
philosophers in the midst of History
this is a quarterly series we've been
doing here hosted by the Frank Weinberg
Library since 2016 so we took a break
during the covid years and we're back to
it now and actually this this session
was supposed to happen last year but I
had covid and so now we're finally
getting to this guy Saint Bonaventure so
the way the series works is it's you
know it's very uh interactive you can
ask questions whenever you want to I
come in I've got you know as you see
like a timeline and I talk about a
particular philosopher and where they
fit into history so it's kind of a back
and forth you know they have a
historical context which which forms
them and shapes what they're interested
in and all of that but then I'm always
I'm almost always picking somebody who
had some info ones on history so we're
not doing somebody obscure who didn't
really have any uh let's say historical
consequences or repercussions and we do
an ancient one in the spring or late
winter in February a medieval thinker in
May and then we do a early modern
thinker so like you know Renaissance up
to say
18th century for August and then in
November we do a later modern thinker
19th or 20th century we haven't done
anyone from the 21st century yet but you
know if the series goes on for decades
and decades maybe we we will someday and
so the person I picked for this time is
somebody who I thought had been a little
bit neglected and he is actually
neglected not just in the series but
also
you could say in the world of of uh
philosophy and theology so it's this guy
Bonaventure
we've done other medieval thinkers
um Augustine big heavy hitter right
everybody knows about the confessions
and city of God and he had a massive
influence on Western uh medieval
Christianity and all the way into the
Renaissance and Reformation we did
boethius uh perhaps one of the you could
say the last of the Romans he and
Augustine are medievals who didn't know
that they were Medieval because they
they just saw a Roman Empire kind of
falling apart we did Anselm of
Canterbury who's much closer to
Bonaventure in time uh we're talking
about an 11th century thinker and 12th
century well yeah
um early 12th century and then we get uh
Thomas Aquinas who we did a couple years
ago
um
and he's a contemporary with with
Bonaventure and he's very famous right
everybody knows about Saint Thomas
because he wasn't officially the
official
philosopher for the Catholic church but
about as close as you could possibly get
right but Bonaventure is also quite
important and specifically for one of
the most important orders within Western
Christianity the franciscans who you
know you see today there's Franciscan
first and second and third order out
there they have a lot of uh works that
they do including teaching unfortunately
I think all of you know local Franciscan
University is closed up Cardinal Stritch
is coming to an end pretty shortly
they're only 10 miles from here and that
was one of the few places around here
where you could actually like learn
about Bonaventure uh Believe It or Not
uh you won't you won't hear about it
much at Marquette or UWM or places like
that but the franciscans love to teach
their own right and he is he's one of
their their main guys so I thought we we
would now focus on a important person
early on in The Franciscan order and
there's a whole bunch of historical
developments that are shaping the mind
of this guy and so I'm going to be going
back and forth between
my notes and the timeline and if there's
something that's unclear at any time
just you know feel free to to ask me
about it so I think that the you could
say that there's four or five really
important historical developments that
are helpful to keep in mind when
thinking about Bonaventure and so of
course the most important of these is
the rise of the Franciscan order and so
what's the Franciscan order it's
oriented around this guy Saint Francis
of Assisi who has a spiritual conversion
starts living a life devoted to
imitation of Christ and part of what
what he focused on the most was poverty
like extreme complete poverty not owning
anything and he drew people to him and
people were like yeah as often happens
with these religious orders there's a
charismatic personality who's going
through some sort of you could call it
experimentation with spiritual life
trying to figure out what can be done
that's new but also something that's
connecting up with the origins of the
religion and so we see that Saint
Francis incredibly devoted to Christ to
the degree that he you know winds up
undergoing uh Stigmata having all sorts
of interesting spiritual experiences
begins teaching preaching Gathering
um whatever we want to call them
converts companions with himself people
who want to live a particular way of
life and so what do you have to do when
that happens well the first thing if
you're going to live together with other
people come on in
um you you know you have to have some
let's call it Mo so modus operandi for
how you're going to live together
whether it's roommates or people in your
dorm there's going to be rules right and
so you know by this time there's a whole
bunch of monastic orders out there Each
of which has its rule you can think
about the order Saint Benedict formed
you know centuries earlier so Francis
comes up with a rule you know here's how
we're going to live together the very
first version we see in
1209 it's called The Guiding Charter and
he starts to you know try to get
official recognition for this new order
that he's founding and the way you do
the it in the Western Christian Church
is to go to Rome and you know to
petition and say hey we got something
cool going on here
um can we can we make this official and
so
we see that you know he goes with his 11
companions telling Pope Innocent III of
this wish for a holy life of poverty
again imitating Christ and and his
disciples and they are going to be what
we call a mendicant order
so this is something fairly new at least
in the west at that time and this is
actually what gets them in trouble a lot
of the time so you know from the
perspective of the more settled
religious orders these guys the
franciscans followers of Saint Francis
and the Dominicans followers of Saint
Dominic they are you know shiftless bums
they're wandering around talking about
God doing their thing but they're
begging from people they don't have a
fixed Abode you know like the
benedictines did for the benedictines
stability is one of the things that they
value you know you get in your your
particular Monastery and you stay in
that Monastery for the rest of your life
unless something bad happens right like
you can't get along with the other monks
or you know somebody sacks your
Monastery and you got to go somewhere
else
these are orders that are
um much more mobile right so they can
serve different needs and the Dominicans
are doing one sort of thing the
franciscans are doing another sort of
thing and uh fairly early on so you know
this is what we call the foundation of
the first order franciscans all guys
and then we get this woman Claire and
she's like well you know this sounds
really great uh what if they were you
know the equivalent of nuns doing this
the the guys are all Friars
um you know the second order is women
often called the poor Claires right and
they are also uh franciscans that are
living out this this sort of
charism or life and
[Music]
um
around this time we see that there is
this um
examination of somebody who's not a
Franciscan but is going to play an
important role in the history uh Joachim
of Flores he's a cistercian from a
little bit earlier and he was actually
given like papal approval for some of
the things that he was doing and he
starts writing these uh these books that
become very popular especially among
some of the franciscans and they will
end up being condemned as heretical and
we'll we'll talk about why and you know
so all of this is is sort of background
information you also see Frederick II is
crowned Holy Roman Emperor and he's
going to be an important player on the
scene and then we get Bonaventure being
born down in the Papal States in in
Italy
to people that we really know almost
nothing about his father is this guy
Giovanni and then his mother is Maria we
basically just know their names and that
his father his father father was a
physician and
um
more stuff is going on with the
franciscans around this time they're
becoming more and more Consolidated uh
Francis creates a more formal rule for
the first order and then they form a
third order and the third order and this
is imitated with some other religious uh
organizations so you've got you know the
committed men the committed women and
then you've got people who are lay
people who are attracted to part of what
the franciscans are doing and you know
they want spiritual guidance from them
that's the third order so Francis is now
taking care of them and then in 1223 the
franciscans get formally established so
not long after Bonaventure himself is
born as the order of Friars minor so you
know whenever you see a Franciscan
writing something and that ofm that's
what the that's what it stands for order
of Friars Meyer just minor just like uh
OSB is Order of Saint Benedict or Opa
order of preachers for the Dominicans
and what we see um happening is Francis
is going to die and you know as with
most movements you're going to have some
successors but there's also going to be
divisions about well what is the
genuinely Franciscan Way of Life and
this is going to assume some real
importance in the life of Bonaventure
later on uh we're and we're gonna we're
gonna talk about that in just a bit the
other thing that I think is important to
bring up about
um
bonaventure's early life looking at the
historical context is he gets sick how
sick we don't know you know a lot of
this is we're fighting you know little
bits and pieces here and there
and it was quite common at the time that
you know you would pray to a saint to
help you out
um and then you know you'd be attached
to that Saint if they if they did and
Francis comes through
Bonaventure recovers and Bonaventure is
now you know quite interested in this
guy Saint Francis so we got the rise of
the Franciscan order and um by by
um
uh 10.50 you know so you know when when
Bonaventure you could say is in his
prime they've got 30 000 members this is
in medieval times too so that's a lot of
people they're spread out all over the
place they are growing like
um I suppose their enemies would say
like a cancer throughout Christendom uh
the franciscans view this as a good
thing right and but they're you know
again they're sort of new on the scene
so that's one part of the story now
another really important part of the
story is the rise of the universities
and the university that's most important
for people like
um uh Bonaventure and some of his later
successors is the University of Paris
so the universities in medieval times
they are educational institutions that
replace or supplant let's say the other
places where education is going on and a
lot of these early places are Cathedrals
or monasteries
so some of the people that we looked at
earlier like Anselm of Canterbury
teaching in a monastery and then
teaching at a cathedral some of the
other people that were you know going to
talk about might have been at Cathedrals
but the university becomes the place to
be right and at Paris so does anybody
know what the three professions that
were like the apexes of the universities
were at the time it wasn't like the
liberal arts those were what you studied
to get there and it wasn't philosophy
philosophy was the next highest thing
there were three main professions
any idea
yeah
those are two of them yeah and and you
would go to different places for those
so like theology that's Paris right
medicine there were a couple places
anyone know what the third one is off
hand
again not philosophy philosophy is kind
of it's a great you know science as they
call it but it's not the Apex law
right so Padua that's the place to go
for for law right so Paris is about
Theology and
you know some of the people who would
study would um would stay there and
teach it's pretty rare though for the
most part what they're doing is they're
they're attracting students who are
going to come there and many of them are
going to become like Parish priests or
they're going to be in the religious
orders and they're studying theology as
well as all of these you know Seven
Liberal Arts and then philosophy so that
they can do a good job so that they
understand human nature so that they
understand the relationship between
humans and God so they can interpret
scripture as part of a literate culture
that's that's developing so that's
that's the university system and
for a long time well yeah for a long
time there weren't any uh mendicant uh
chairs uh teaching in it because there
weren't the orders the universities
precede these and then you know as I
mentioned a lot of people looked at
these uh mendicant orders like the
Dominicans and the franciscans is a
bunch of dirty bums you know who are
traveling around begging people for
money not exactly University Professor
material you could say right so that's
that's another big part of it and then
we get this guy so now we have a conflux
between two different things Francis can
order universities Alexander of Hales
this is the guy who Bonaventure is going
to study with first
Alexander is a major heavy hitter
philosopher Theologian he enters the
Franciscan order he he's you know sort
of a late convert to it and he
previously had considered two other
groups one was the Dominicans right so
he's attracted to this this idea he also
considered the cistercians who are you
could say a reform as they would call it
or an offshoot as their original
benedictines would call it of the
Benedictine order and he decided no I
want to be a Franciscan there was
something about that that charism of
poverty that he thought was attractive
and he is a he becomes the first
Franciscan to hold a university chair at
Paris so this is quite uh important and
he was what we would call a Scholastic
now when we use that term today it's
just got a very general meaning of like
people who are studying something right
or teaching like we have Scholastic Book
Fairs and things like that but the
Scholastics in the Middle Ages
these were people who were engaging in
philosophy and you know Theology and
perhaps also you could say some of the
people involved with law were doing this
and it was a an approach
more than anything else
so to be a Scholastic meant that you
were going to be using argumentation
and looking at what other people before
you had said about a topic and seeing
what you thought was right and what was
wrong and sort of like bringing in the
best stuff what earlier thinkers like
Aristotle and Plato called the
dialectical method
and then forming your own come on in
your own new sort of synthesis your own
new way of thinking about uh the matters
and you would argue with other people
right and you would put forth uh
documents that some of which were called
Sumas like you know you were going to
cover everything that's what a summa
actually means or it might be a
commentary on a particular piece of
scripture then you'd weave in all sorts
of other stuff as well or you might be
commenting on some previous thinkers
work like boethius or Augustine or
somebody like that and so that's what
Alexander is doing and uh just as an
example of you know the kind of approach
when he's considering the question of
what is Free Will he'll look at
Augustine's definition of Free Will and
then he looks at Anselm of canterbury's
definition of Free Will and then he
looks at Bernard of clairvo's definition
of Free Will and he's like well I like
this about this one not so big on this
part I think they got this wrong and he
tries to bring them together in sort of
a synthesis of his own and that's what
he teaches to his students and among
those students would be
Bonaventure yeah
oh they were interested in everything
that's one of like hundreds of topics
that they would address but
Free Will is absolutely Central because
if if you're
thinking about like how does a person
actually make moral decisions you have
to ask questions like well what are we
responsible for where are we free and
where are we conditioned by something
else to what degree are we responsible
you know so in order to figure that out
you you can't just look at the question
of well how much
you have to think about what is free
will what what does that look like right
so then there's different models that
are that are out there already by the
time that Alexander is on the scene
so
um but they do this with like pick any
any Topic in general that we might be
interested in and they're I mean
obviously not like how cell phones work
but
um all the other things that are really
important to philosophy and theology
these these people are exploring it in
the universities so that's that's
another part of the picture yeah go
ahead
did they assume there was free will or
did
or did sure they did both
I mean we're talking about people who
had a very wide breadth of thinking
about things
there's no like just assuming a party
line or something like that in
scholasticism you go to the bottom of
things so
so we're talking here about like
different uh historical background
matters so Alexander is going to be
somebody really important for
Bonaventure but unfortunately not long
after Bonaventure gets there and begins
studying with him he dies and so
Bonaventure is going to have to study
with with some other people
um
and um
some of the other background stuff
before we look directly at what
Bonaventure
um has to say
so we've talked so far about religious
people now we're going to talk about
somebody who's
accused of being irreligious
um although ironically he's the emperor
of the Holy Roman Empire right so the
holy
you think that he is actually religious
but Frederick II was uh
pretty secular you know and he is the
king you could say of the Germans also
of large parts of Italy
also of Sicily also of Jerusalem and a
kingdom that doesn't exist anymore
burgundy right so he's got a lot of
power and apparently the guy was like an
intellectual Dynamo you know he he
actually writes one of the first
treatises on birds of prey on falconry
um so he had the time to do that in
addition to all the other things that
he's doing and he's a massive patron of
the Arts and Sciences he's kind of one
of these Larger than Life characters
winds up being excommunicated three
times
um and then you know you can tell gets
back in because you can't get
excommunicated more than once if you
haven't also managed to to get in he's
the guy who you know you hear about
Frederick you know kneeling in front of
the Pope in the snow that's the guy
right but it didn't really stick
you could say so he goes on doing his
stuff and
um you know he's involved in the
Crusades that you can see on the
timeline happening in in this time and
interestingly Dante who's coming you
know about another Century later Dante
is going to place him in Hell In The
Inferno he's going to place him in the
sixth circle of hell where the pagans
and the
um
he calls him an Epicurean right where
all those dirty people you know who deny
the faith are are stuck so you can tell
there's a lot of people that don't like
Frederick II but there's also a lot of
people who really do like Frederick uh
the second and we're going to get to to
him in a bit and then we get this other
guy who now we've almost got all the
pieces of the puzzle that we need I
mentioned him already youachima Fiore he
is a cistercian Abbott and theologian
and he um comes up with this theory of
the Three Ages that other people have
used uh subsequent to him and the idea
is that the first age is that of the Old
Testament the you know the Jewish
scriptures
um prior to Christ and then we have the
second age which is the age of Christ
and the church and you know
institutionalized and you know the New
Testament and all of that sort of stuff
and then he says there's going to be a
third age and that that age is starting
now back in you know the 1200s or
actually 1100s
um in which the church would become
unnecessary and it would be the age of
the Holy Spirit uh infidels would
reunite with Christians everybody would
be living in this kind of utopian era
that that Humanity just now has to bring
about and one of the ways you bring it
about would be like rejecting the
institutional church and
um you know aiming at this new Spiritual
Development well you can guess that did
not go over greatly with the
institutional church and in addition to
this he he also said that there would be
popes who would be the Antichrist
um now you know if you think about
Renaissance pulps
maybe he wasn't wrong about some of this
um and then he also said that Rome is
the Babylon represented in the Book of
Revelation so if you ever hear like you
know
um Protestant polemics from much much
later on they're probably not coming
directly from you I came to Fury but
they're echoing what he what he says
about that so this you know this is very
attractive to a lot of people within the
church but the church as a whole
condemned that as heretical and it turns
out to have been although he was a
cistercian very very attractive for many
franciscans and many of these
franciscans instead of saying the pope
was the Antichrist they said Frederick
II was the Antichrist so now you got all
this apocalyptic stuff going on right so
Bonaventure is wandering into this as a
young Franciscan Friar as a student you
know uh in the University of Paris sort
of like the center of intellectual life
in Western Europe at the time and you
know the franciscans are going through
several changes and conflicts and um
we're going to start seeing some battle
lines being drawn before too long
and uh Bonaventure is witnessing all of
this
so we'll we'll get to those conflicts in
just a bit
um and how Bonaventure becomes the
um you know the person essentially in
charge of
um the entire order but on the way he's
going to do a few things that I just
want to mention very quickly so he gets
licensed as a bachelor now when we think
about a bachelor degree right that's our
beginning in our contemporary thing
being licensed is a bachelor meant that
he could teach but he could only teach
certain subjects
so he can teach the Bible meaning he can
do commentary on scripture which you
know is kind of helpful because there's
a lot of confusing stuff in the Bible
students would need some you know
discussion and and review about and then
he begins reading this really important
text and and to go back to Alexander of
Hales Alexander is one of the first
people to comment on this it's called
Peter Lombard's sentences and Peter
Lombard is one of these early
Scholastics and one of the ways in which
you approach things as a Scholastic is
you say here's a topic
um what do people think about it here's
some arguments for a question here's
some arguments against the question
let's look at these arguments are they
any good right so Peter Lombard did this
in let's say a less sophisticated way he
his sentences are just a whole slew of
topics which would include free will but
also all sorts of other things under the
sun and then he'd like gather what
people had said about it and so there's
four and against and then it's up to you
to figure out what to do with them as
the student and so different people
would have different commentaries where
they would take the same material and
say well I think that Augustine is right
about this but wrong about this and I
prefer what John damaskeen has to say or
pick whoever else you want right and so
this is this is an important part of the
work and
um during this time uh Bonaventure is
going to get involved in a controversy
that we'll talk a little bit more about
in a bit having to do again with those
you know
franciscans being looked at as kind of
shiftless bombs by the other people that
are involved in the university and so he
writes a piece to defend them and
there's other you know people debating
this this sort of uh matter and
eventually
um he gets awarded the Master's Degree
now we think of a masters as kind of
sometimes a terminal degree like if you
have an MBA or you know master of Fine
Arts right but in that time that was
that was it there wasn't any PhD right
the Masters was you were at the highest
level now you can teach whatever you
want to teach whatever you think is
worth doing within the curriculum and
you have students that are following you
and he's awarded the master's degree but
he doesn't actually get to teach as a
master for a couple years because of
this controversy that's going on same
thing by the way is happening to Thomas
Aquinas who is his contemporary so
finally in um 1257 he has received as a
masters at the University of Paris and
same year he doesn't get to teach a hell
of a lot because he winds up getting
kicked upstairs as often happens with
these interesting religious figures and
if any of you remember uh Anselm of
Canterbury you know the guy who didn't
want to be an Abbott didn't want to be
Archbishop of Canterbury but got stuck
doing that or the predecessor Gregory
the Great the pope who didn't want to be
a pope but he was the guy for the job
and they made him do it so Bonaventure
is going to become the
um the head the
um the minister general of The
Franciscan order so he's at the top you
know and he is the seventh because since
Francis has died they've had all these
different people in charge
some of whom were actually quite opposed
to each other one of them actually had
to leave and take shelter with Frederick
Elias with Frederick II
um so you know you can tell things are
really really bad when you got to go
over to the enemy and take shelter there
so what did Bonaventure actually teach
what did he think about things
um so we could say that he's broadly
augustinian he identifies as a follower
of Saint Augustine but that's a little
bit deceptive
because there's a whole bunch of other
stuff that's getting like thrown into
the the mix the The Cauldron you could
say so he's influenced heavily by
Augustine but also by this guy
um he's sometimes called Dionysus the
aeropagite
um but we nowadays call them pseudo
Dionysus pseudo means fake right so
um he's not the dnsist that was a friend
of Saint Paul he was some later
neoplatonist writer who wound up writing
some cool stuff and being very
influential there were also these guys
from the the monastery of Saint Victor
Hugh and Richard so we're talking about
earlier monastic writers who are kind of
on the edge of scholasticism Anselm of
Canterbury we mentioned already is a is
a big influence on Bonaventure Bernard
of clairvo if you know about him he's a
little bit later he is somebody who
preaches a lot about love about you know
how we Ascend to God through that's a
Bonaventure and theme as well as a
clairvoyant theme and of course
Alexander of Hales but there's another
character in the mix
who's going to
depending on how you look at it
totally screw things up
provide the absolutely needed answers or
something in between
who would you think
in the 13th century in the universities
who would be the most controversial
philosopher
whose works are becoming available
and are sort of like a bomb going off
within the intellectual culture any
ideas
it's not Augustine it's not not Plato
it had Augustine for a long time
they're not going to get most of Plato's
tax until the Renaissance
I'll give you a hint his his texts are
coming from Spain where they're being
translated
um
it was a big translation project going
on
any idea
his stuff is in Latin he's readily
available Aristotle
the philosopher as he's often called
right and not just Aristotle but
commentaries by aristotelians mostly
Islamic aristotelians but a few of them
Jewish on Aristotle like Ava Rosa you've
been rushed right or uh maimonides right
so Thomas Aquinas and his uh predecessor
Albert the greater gobbling this stuff
up right they are aristotelians although
they are also Christians Bonaventure is
also encountering Aristotle and this is
going to be an important part of his his
work
um now he is a theologian more than a
philosopher in the sense that you know
he thinks of what he's doing as Theology
and philosophy as like all the other
Arts and Sciences being a handmaid of
theology meaning you know
um
secondary but he does think that
philosophy is very important you need to
study philosophy it's it's very useful
for figuring things out so you know what
you've got here is yet another person
putting together a synthesis of
Aristotle representing philosophy and a
whole bunch of other neoplatonist
philosophers and sacred scripture and
what other you know big Christian
thinkers have had to say about this and
try to bring it together in some sort of
coherent rational but not rationalistic
synthesis something that can lead to God
and help illuminate you know our life
and recognize you know where the proper
limits are and that's a tough thing to
pull off right so
that's what Bonaventure is is uh engaged
in
and
um
one of the key ideas that you see him
working out
That You Don't See in Thomas Aquinas for
example is what we call Divine
illumination
so Augustine Way Way Back in the 300s
400s was saying that
um we you know how is our mind Illumina
how does our mind get ideas part of it
is a light that is coming from God
within our our souls or our minds which
is Illuminating the ideas think of it as
sort of like somebody having a big
flashlight except you know not like one
of the piddly flashlights that we have
but actually think like a stadium light
just burning in and Illuminating these
things sometimes so bright you can't
even make it out unless your eyes are
strong enough so the the idea of an
illumination is that
um
God is ultimately giving us what we need
in order to understand ideas and so the
soul needs to make itself ready for that
how does it do that well prayer is one
big part of it and you know religious
people do pray so he's got that covered
exercising the virtues good character
traits eliminating vices like greed or
Envy or anger right
um and then you know using reason uh in
order to to understand these matters
meditation
and all of this can be connected and
this is what what Bonaventure does
you can think about it in terms of like
Augustine and these other Christian
authors and the metaphors that they're
using but what do we do with this guy
Aristotle over here who's got things to
say about the human mind well Aristotle
had this idea of abstraction that we
look at things for example Human Being
Human Being Human Being how do I
actually see Humanity in each of you
well I abstract this this general idea
and it exists in my mind somehow it's
like a copy right of what it is that's
in each one of us or chair or pick
whatever else we want I mean I don't
know that there's an actual like
um abstracted idea of hot dog but maybe
a sandwich you know something I mean
Aristotle doesn't talk about that
because there are no as far as I know
sandwiches at the time
um but you know we could we could go on
and on and on with this sort of thing or
we think about like
Technology phone artifacts they would
call it right so
these ideas that are in our mind are
being illuminated
um by God but we're also drawing them
partly from the world and there's this
is bonaventure's idea about that now how
can that happen
well this is all tied in with his
understanding of creation
and as opposed to Thomas Aquinas who
says well
you know Aristotle thought that the
world was eternal
you can't really prove it one way or the
other I mean the faith tells us that God
made the world in seven days whatever
the hell days are I mean none of these
medievals actually thought it was
literally days because they were smart
enough to realize that you don't have
any passage of time before there's light
right and they didn't think of it as
like physical single 24-hour periods but
you know Aquinas is like saying well
Aristotle says the universe is eternal
scripture says that it had a beginning
in time A Reason can't really decide we
just we just got to take this as a
matter of Faith Bonaventure says no no
we can use philosophy to say Aristotle's
wrong
about this and that
um you know the world is created and I'm
going to tell you about it's it's
creation what is it like when God
creates things
so he draws on this idea and again this
is coming from Augustine and Augustine
also got this from pre-christian
thinkers called the stoics there's this
notion of what are called
[Music]
um
um you could translate it as rational
seeds or
seed principles seminal principles is
often how it's translated
and the idea is that within God's mind
before God even begins to create
there are already the ideas of things
and it could be a real General like you
know Human Being Human Being Human Being
or it could be real specific like this
human being depends on whose theory
you're looking at
it and so when God creates through the
second person of the Trinity the word
all these ideas are contained in the
word and boom we get a world and that
world has different kinds of things in
it Each of which came from this
um rational seed that we all came from
one kind of rational scene
um the birds out there I mean
I don't know if like I haven't really
thought this out I don't know if there's
like a different rational seed for each
kind of bird you know or like classes of
birds or maybe all birds or something
like that but you know maybe there's a
rational seed for crow and a different
rational seed for uh Robin and a
different rational seed for chickadee or
something like that but
these are the the principles that allow
an intelligible World in which we can
have all this cause and effect going on
and you know it winds up being quite
quite uh wonderful so
Divine creation is at the center of
of uh his his ideas
and he also says and this is typical you
know Christian thinking about it did God
have to create no
it's totally gratuitous
you know
um why did God make things the way they
are that's
it right uh we can like go a little bit
into the reasons for why things are the
way they are but fundamentally it comes
down to an expression of divine
creativity love flowing out into an
entire universe and he talks about the
again not a
uniquely Bonaventure and phrase a book
of creation creation itself is this
world that we see is like a book and
what do you do with books you read them
right and you read them not just for
entertainment which you can do but to
understand things so if we could
actually read this creation
we would understand how God put
everything together and why things are
as they are and we would just be in awe
of it so why aren't we having this
experience all the time
because we're kind of blind
we
we don't get it why not because we're
all messed up from you know sin and
vices and you know the damage that was
done to us
um and we we also get mixed up because
of this about Humanity's place in the
cosmos
Bonaventure thought that we as the kind
of beings that we are
were sort of like God's helpers we're
we're here to participate in a way
different than all the other animals
with this vast beautiful amazing world
that we live in and so the human being
is you know like it says in Genesis and
also in the book of wisdom made in the
image of God
right and so what is that image well
it's the capacities for things like
remembering and understanding and loving
all of those things together are sort of
Trinity almost like a model as Augustine
said and Saint Anselm said of the
Trinity the Divine Trinity you know
we've got a little bit of that in us now
for Bonaventure
um he's mostly interested in one person
of the Trinity it's not the holy spirit
it's not the father it's the son it's
you know this this uh God that becomes
carnal becomes flesh becomes this this
human being Jesus Christ who then is
represented in the gospels and all of
that well this is also coming from Saint
Francis Francis thought that Christ has
to be absolutely Central his model has
to be followed which includes not just
you know Chastity but like poverty and
you know love for for everybody
including animals as part of The
Franciscan vision and so um Bonaventure
actually has this really interesting
metaphor of Christ as being the uh he's
got a whole book about this the Tree of
Life
and now we we don't do a lot with trees
I think these days you know we may trim
them or you know
um cut them down as a matter of fact as
we're driving up on uh 43 there's an
awful lot of money that's been spent in
the last couple weeks on cutting trees
down and there's lots of brush and logs
and stuff like that
one thing that you do with trees
especially if they're fruit trees
is grafting
grafting is when you like cut a little
bit into it and then you stick another
plant into that tree and it becomes
organically part of that tree this is
where we get a lot of our fruits from
right you know we graph things onto each
other so for Bonaventure Christ God
incarnate is the tree and each one of us
is grafted
into this tree and now the question is
are we going to like grow into it and be
part of the fabric of that or are we
going to like be our own independent
people and get in the way of the tree
and get rejected from the tree right so
it's kind of an interesting metaphor
that he's using and I was actually going
to talk about
um a bit more but I I want to be
respectful of
time so I'll just talk about two of his
works very very briefly one is called
the Journey of the Mind into God
probably his most famous work and one
good thing about Bonaventure is most of
his works are pretty short pretty easy
to get through you know and so he uh in
the Journey of the mind to God
he's going to lay out a bunch of
different steps how do we ascend from
you know the people that we are to this
whatever God is
and I'll just tell you about one part of
it he talks about there being six steps
of Ascension into God and there are six
steps of the Soul's Powers so he's doing
a psychology or as we would call it a
philosophical anthropology there so
first we go from the exterior things to
Interior things and then from temporal
things to Eternal so we go from our
senses to imagination which is a second
hire to reason
intellect something that goes beyond
intellect that he calls intelligence and
then finally to this is very interesting
what they called Cinder races this is
coming from a Greek term
and it's not what we can translate as
conscience
but it's rather what informs our
conscience you know conscience is like
when we do the wrong thing there's a
part of ourselves that's like hey knock
it off you shouldn't do that right so
Cinder Aces is the part of us that's
sort of like a bit of God inside of us
that guides us towards what's right or
wrong so it's it's not fundamentally
speculative where like oh we're gonna
you know have a theory about God it's
leading to experience of God
ultimately through love and and joy and
and Bliss
in the uh revoloquium another one of his
very short Works where he's concerned
with how to interpret scripture he says
you basically got four kinds of
scriptural works legal historical
sapiential and prophetic so you have
this in what he calls the Old Testament
the Jewish writings you know the legal
are the first five books the Torah
you've got the prophets you've got the
sapiential meaning wisdom literature
like
um you know Proverbs and Ecclesiastes
and the Psalms and then you have
prophetic where you know you've got all
these prophets saying this is going to
happen or hey knock it off you're
oppressing the poor one of the most
common prophetic um
uh things that that get said like in
Amos and Isaiah and so that makes good
sense for the Old Testament
and he says this actually holds for the
New Testament too the law the new law is
given in the four Gospels
the um
uh historical work acts right very short
work
um the sample stuff the wisdom
literature that's the letters Paul's and
you know James and Peter and John and we
could go on and on and on and then
finally what's the prophetic book The
Book of Revelation
um so the New Testament conforms to this
and then he says that there's four ways
of prompting somebody towards good and
Away From Evil and this is so again he's
very interested in moral theology or
philosophy one way is laws of a Majesty
supremely powerful so that's the legal
part right another is the teachings of a
truth supremely wise that is the uh
sapiential part the the third is
examples and benefits of a goodness
supremely pure the historical part and
then finally the combination of all
three is the prophetic
interestingly so he's got you know a
breakdown of how to understand
um sacred scripture and words
um now I I said that we'd get to talking
about conflicts
um before we jump into that I've been
talking at you quite a quite a while any
any questions about the stuff that I've
covered so far about this guy
Bonaventure yeah go ahead I I just I
wanted to ask you about the introduction
of aristel I wasn't sure oh yeah
I wasn't sure
it was fun adventure just rejecting some
parts of him yeah and and
how did the introduction of of the
writings by Muslims or Jews influence
Christians Christian thinking or did
they reject it or no they as a matter of
fact some of them were too accepting of
it for people like Bonaventure so this
is actually a good good segue into one
of the big conflicts that was taking
place which has to do with Aristotle so
you know Aristotle's works are getting
translated into Latin and then they're
which is what has to happen in order for
them to be usable by these people
because they for the most part can't
read Greek right and it comes across the
the uh Pyrenees into France and then
through the rest of Europe because Spain
at the time was still Muslim right so
Christendom essentially ends at the the
Pyrenees except for a few Christian
Kingdoms in in that area
so Aristotle is making his way in and
people are like well this is really good
you know we we do have some other
philosophers like we've got Seneca and
we've got you know we did they did have
a few texts by Aristotle and Plato
namely the uh
um categories and the on interpretation
by Aristotle and the Timaeus by Plato
which does cover a lot of ground
um boethius had translated those and
they had Cicero and they had some other
people but Aristotle's full Works
including a couple works that also
weren't by Aristotle but were being
attributed to Aristotle because they
didn't know any better
this is like you know imagine being
given and we I mean there's actually no
no nothing like it in our day you know
um imagine we were given like a library
of stuff that we'd never come across and
it seemed pretty plausible you know we
were like holy crap you know I mean we
talk about like the Dead Sea Scrolls
that's kind of like what was going on it
expands your capacities to think about
things and Aristotle seems pretty good
you know so there's some people who
Embrace him completely
um including doctrines that seem to go
against Christianity like the world is
eternal well if the world's Eternal then
how do you get that God created the
world right there's a direct conflict
there
um or you know to give you an example
from moral philosophy
Aristotle says
because Aristotle is essentially a
materialist in this respect when you die
that's it there is no afterlife
um so happiness exists here in this life
now it doesn't mean doing whatever the
hell you want right you got to like live
a good life and have friends and you
know develop the virtues but compared to
what Christianity is saying namely that
well you do need the virtues but that's
so you get to heaven
contradiction there again right and so
we've got Aristotle and then we've got
these commentators
um some of whom by the way are some are
Muslim right so we have you know IBN
Cena and Ava Rose and people like that
and we have Moses maimonides they also
had um they had a few Christian
aristotelians like John damaskeen who'd
already been around and there was a guy
uh Alexander of aphrodisias who's a
pagan
um and he's he's actually called the
commentator by the Scholastics because
he was viewed as so important so you got
all this this stuff going on and people
get very enthusiastic about it and so
some people are like well screw the
Christianity stuff Aristotle's right you
know if the Bible contradicts Aristotle
so much worse for the Bible so those are
the avaros those are the people who are
um kind of radicals within the academy
and then you get like a counter response
you've got people on the other end who
are like see that's what that Aristotle
stuff is going to get you into get rid
of him all together he's a heretic you
know and then you get poor people in
between who are like well wait a second
can't we use some of this stuff I mean
he Aristotle is certainly a powerful
thinker can't we like take the good
stuff and reject what we don't like and
you know he doesn't have to be the only
philosopher that we listen to and so
that's like Thomas Aquinas and
Bonaventure and interestingly Thomas
Aquinas because he's he's not an avarice
he's not an Aristotle only guy but the
bishop of Paris goes after him you know
trying to condemn uh propositions the
way that you would go after people at
that time as you say these propositions
that a person holds I won't say who's
holding them but we all know who they
are uh these are uh anathema these are
against the faith and uh if anybody's
teaching this stuff they better knock it
off it's without mentioning uh who it is
and so this is part of what's going on
right and uh you could say that in the
medieval University these things aren't
really worked out completely there's
there's always these battles being
fought within it uh long after
Bonaventure and Thomas have have left
the scene
um the irony is is that Aristotle
is going to wind up being rejected about
300 400 years later by modern
philosophers who are like yeah get rid
of all this this stuff he succeeded too
much so that's one main like line of
conflict
um another major line of conflict that's
also happening in the University that I
mentioned already is before the
franciscans and Dominicans who are
mendicant orders wandering around you
know
taking taken alms and stuff like that
before they get shares and then soon
after Alexander of Hales gets a chair
um the other people in the university
the
um you can call them seculars just
meaning they're not in in religious
orders
um
they uh
you know they're the regular teachers
they're like we don't want these bombs
in here
who's giving them chairs what the hell
is going on here you know this is going
to undermine the university and so one
of them actually writes a book called
The Perils of the last times right look
at these dirty scumbags coming in to
take over our University it's sort of
like people you know are always like
saying oh you know the university isn't
what it used to be these days right
um and so Bonaventure and other people
get involved in this he writes this
treaties on the poverty of Christ saying
you know the guy that you claim you love
so much well he was a Wandering bum too
just like us franciscans and
um you know eventually the pope has to
get involved Alexander IV he sends
envoys and they threaten the university
officials with excommunication and
that's what allows him and Thomas
Aquinas to finally get their their
positions as as Masters so that's that's
now we got two different controversies
right we got the aristotelianism we got
the men orders and then within the
franciscans
we've got two other kinds of conflicts
going on so Francis you know he's he's a
guy who's poor voluntarily wanders
around getting alms preaching loving
people you know I mean you've always
seen the thing like preaching to the
birds and stuff like that very
attractive personality
immediately people after he dies start
writing lives of him or legenda actually
the word that we get Legend from and
some of these are very very radiographic
you know the guy could basically walk on
water and as we say butter wouldn't melt
in his mouth and you know all the
different things that he's teaching
through his life and the franciscans
break into two different camps and the
conflict gets so bad
that it actually becomes a schism
within different Franciscan houses
the Abbott of the house can't get the
other people to do what they're supposed
to do and the conflict has to do with
poverty so there are those who are much
more strict they're they they call
themselves The spirituals or the
observance right
they're like Francis gave us a rule the
rule says absolute poverty you cannot
own anything we're going to live by this
now that's kind of tough right well what
about a toothbrush I mean toothbrushes
weren't common at the time but we would
probably bring that up most likely uh
can I have a toothbrush or do I have to
like sign it out every night you know
from from the guy who's in charge of
toothbrushes for the time being
um what about uh as I'm wandering around
can I have some like food with me or you
know like a like a satchel that I can
put the food in or is that too much
right so this the spirituals are very
very strict about this and then there's
those who are called the the lacks by
the spirituals or called the uh Convent
the conventials by themselves
um the the Latin word for the for the
lacks is the relaxy right they're too
willing to compromise but they're
they're actually more reasonable they're
like well
okay we got to think this through let's
be let's be uh thoughtful about this
obviously we don't want to have like
individual Friars owning a ton of stuff
right you don't need a 401k
um you don't need a palace somewhere to
retire to but you got to have some
things like your your clothes can be
your clothes right
um and there were also questions too
about like how should you beg you know
and then where should the alms go to do
they go directly to the thing or can can
a guy who's like out in the boonies
begging can he take some of those alms
and buy himself some food rather than
having to go back and say Here's the
money can I have some of that so this
turns into a huge huge battle and
different
um people in charge adopt one side or
the other
Bonaventure when he comes in he's got to
adjudicate between these two
and he takes a middle position he's like
you know he's spirituals you're kind of
full at yourselves
um you're not being very Christian
towards your your brethren there's also
going to be one other problem with the
sphericals which we'll talk about in a
minute and you relax see sometimes you
can be a little bit too relaxed
um we want to maintain good discipline
right we don't want to like say anything
goes it's saw he's towing a middle line
and that's that's going to be really
important that's part of his his legacy
the other thing that has to do with the
order
we mentioned you know I came to Fiore
right so he he proved to be most
attractive to franciscans and he proved
to be most attractive to spiritual
franciscans some of whom started going
around preaching this third age stuff
and that was a big No-No right it got
condemned Bonaventure has to bring up
some of these people on charges
including the guy who'd been in charge
before him who had suggested when he
stepped down he had suggested that
Bonaventure was the guy for the job and
then he got elected to it he had to
bring these people up on on charges as
Heretics before an ecclesiastical
tribunal the guy was John of Parma his
predecessor so now we've got like four
different controversies going on that
Bonaventure is involved in and then the
last one that leads up to him dying
maybe even dying because of it
nobody really knows
so you know in the west we had the Latin
church Church of Rome
we call it the Roman Catholic church
right and things are being done in Latin
and then to the east we have the Eastern
Orthodox Church centered in
Constantinople there's other Eastern
churches as well the Coptic the uh you
know Syrian Church of the East really
far off and in uh you know what's
nowadays Iraq
um there was uh the very Syriac Church
they're not really involved it's more of
a Greek Roman thing right
there was a Schism going on which was
not helped by the fact that the
crusaders had sacked Constantinople
either right that produced a lot of bad
blood but there's a Schism about
um who's in charge is it the guy in Rome
is it the guy in Constantinople is it a
bunch of people you know how should we
do things for example should the bread
for communion be leavened as it is in
the west should it be unleavened or
unleavened or leavened rather as it is
in the East Anselm of Canterbury
actually waded in on that one earlier
and so the two churches were you know
kind of hostile to each other right and
there's a lot of polemics going on
between them but they wanted to get back
together
so
they have this Council which is called
the second Council of Leon held of
course in Leon which is a major
um
ecclesiastical site supposedly uh after
it was convened there were 500 Bishops
involved 60 abbots more than a thousand
different prelates or pro-curators
um
St Thomas Aquinas gets summoned by the
pope to help out he dies on the way
this is when he has his famous all of my
work is strong didn't even know about
this uh famous I'll tell you real quick
about this because it's not so much
about Thomas but Thomas is on his way
traveling to Lyon to take part in this
and he has some sort of fit and he
recovers from it and then
um he says he's in the middle of writing
two of his last works the somatelogia
which he didn't finish up he was on the
third part of it at that time and then
the commentary on the Psalms which he
only got to Psalm 54 and didn't even
finish that one and when he recovers
shortly before he dies he's like I'm not
writing anything more and everyone's
like no no you got to finish your books
and he's like everything I've written is
as strong meaning worthless right and
this is the guy who's written a lot of
really important things but apparently
he had some you know experience of God
and was like yeah I didn't I didn't
didn't really manage it
Bonaventure then he's on his way to the
council and the pope is like this is the
guy who's going to lead the council that
will bring east and west back together
and it kind of does for a little bit but
you know obviously didn't didn't stick
Bonaventure dies at the council
and some people think he was poisoned
nobody really knows
he's got you know sick and died very
rapidly
and uh you know the pope had given the
direction of the council to Bonaventure
so he was kind of the guy in charge so
we have another controversy that
Bonaventure is involved in and this is
kind of the story of his life right he
he wants to do Theology and philosophy
but he's always getting embroiled in all
of this historical stuff all this
baggage you could say
and so we should finish up by talking
about his influence and then you know
doing some q a so his most important
thing that he ever did was keep the
Franciscan order from breaking up
he is the compromise candidate who turns
out to be the right guy for the job the
reason why we even have a Franciscan
order still around today in the form
that it is is because Bonaventure was
the seventh guy in charge and he was
able to bring things together he
actually wrote a life of Saint Francis
and then the franciscans ordered all the
previous lives destroyed he issued a new
constitution for the order all the
earlier constitutions were annulled
right he is the guy to bring order to
the order you could say and and
reconcile these these competing parts
in theology unfortunately I think
because I think he's a pretty cool uh
thinker he uh is going to be supplanted
by another Franciscan thinker Don scotus
who is going to live from about 1265 to
um and so you know the Dominicans they
have Thomas they they are Thomas the
franciscans were often scotus right and
these are the two conflicting things
there weren't a hell of a lot of
bonaventurians out there by the time
that scotus comes on the scene and then
we have William avakum who you may have
heard of a famous nominalist he's also a
Franciscan and you know if you go to
Franciscan school and you go to the
philosophy Department you're like hey do
you do franciscans they'll be like yeah
we do scotus Occam and Bonaventure but
they're probably doing more scotus and
Occam than they are Bonaventure in most
cases he is very widely read in
Franciscan communities for his
devotional works
his theological works
for example The Life of Francis if
you've ever read the little flowers
that's bonaventure's work right
um The Mines Road to God or the the
itinerary of the Mind together there's
different ways of translating it the
Tree of Life
um the Soliloquy on the four spiritual
exercises and the triple way these are
all sort of like standard fare in uh
Franciscan Retreats and you know here's
some reading for you so Bonaventure
still has an important role there and
you know you can tell that you made it
in the Catholic church because you get
canonized right you become a saint so it
took a while for him
1482 you know a couple hundred years
later he's he's canonized by Pope sixtus
the the fourth and you can also tell
that you made it in the church as an
intellectual if they call you a doctor
so he is the seraphic doctor and he gets
that title in 1588 by Pope sixtus the
the fifth and what does it mean to be a
doctor it means that you're being
endorsed as somebody for the whole
church as somebody who's worth reading
who's not going to steer you wrong right
and there's a ton of different doctors
there's nothing that says you have to
read any particular doctor but you know
it's like a imprimatur it's like uh go
ahead and read this this person you know
and you know he probably you could say
has a bit less influence on History than
some of the other thinkers that we've
looked at in the past like say you know
Thomas Aquinas or Augustine or Nietzsche
or Albert Camus or you know Aristotle
but he did have a role in history he's
formed by this history he's shaped by it
it determines what he wants to talk
about uh jobs the poor guy gets stuck
doing right and he uh he's responsible
for us
having a Franciscan order in the present
that looks like what it does today is
still Dynamic order
um well you know I'll mention that it's
kind of a shame that The Franciscan
University just down the road from here
is closing right a cardinal stretch
because now where are you going to go to
learn about Bonaventure rather than a
talk here I don't really know I don't
think they teach him at Marquette or I
sometimes teach
um pretty sure they're not teaching them
at UWM there may be some other places
you know but it's very dependent on
somebody actually like liking
Bonaventure enough to want to teach a
class maybe if you take a medieval
philosophy class
they might have them in there along with
Aquinas and Augustine and people like
that but
so that's that's all I've got
um I know that you've got questions
um or comments that you want to make
um it's quite an exciting figure I think
you know for a guy who spent much of his
life hearing about other people's
problems and trying to
figure them out
living living in poverty as much as he
could you know and I will say this too
he appears to have been somebody who
didn't just talk the talk he really
walked the walk you know he was all
about
um Christ and how we could connect with
with that and then using philosophy to
make our way into that using anything
that he came across you could say to
direct it towards this ultimate Ender or
goal so any any questions or comments or
clarifications confusions yeah
well why in in what ways was he
supplanted oh
yeah so
um you know Bonaventure is offering like
a lot of these Scholastics let's call it
a system you know a systematic approach
to things if you think about Thomas
Aquinas his contemporary who dies almost
you know the same time as he does and it
was uh coming up in the same institution
Thomas writes a somate elogia now he
doesn't finish it but it gets pretty
close to finished right so it like
covers everything
and I think that's very attractive to a
lot of people with Bonaventure you don't
have a work like that you have all these
different things you know scriptural
commentaries you know he writes
commentaries for example I thought I
might get asked about this so I made
sure to get it down
um Ecclesiastes gospel Luke Gospel of
John he writes a Life of Christ a Life
of Francis of Assisi he does have some
you know some works like the Journey of
the Soul into God or the the spiritual
exercises but he's not he's not writing
the same kind of thing and Don scotus is
done scotus is
providing the
systematic approach that um
people really want
and So within I mean they're not reading
him a hell of a lot outside of The
Franciscan order because why would they
you know the benedictines think these
franciscans are a bunch of scumbags you
know they've got their own Benedict
others the the Dominicans they got St
Thomas so it's really within the frame
of of the franciscans and Don scotus
gives them more of what they are looking
for
intellectually systematically you know
um but it's you know it's kind of a
shame because
what Bonaventure brings to the table is
quite cool you know
so any other questions or comments yeah
it just dawned on me there's a fancy
hotel in Los Angeles called The
Bonaventure Hotel interesting
um
stories
is it connected with the franciscans at
all or no I used to work for IBM and
yeah I mean usually if you see like a
saint Bonaventure school or something
like that there's usually going to be
some connection to franciscans per se
right
yeah yeah that sounds interesting
um although it could have been
that there was a guy who came from a
Catholic Family who liked Bonaventure
named him Bonaventure and then he became
a hotel magnet and you know they just
named it after him like the Hyatt or you
know the Hilton or stuff like that
um there's probably quite a few like
that right there's probably a you know
it's probably a Saint Thomas hotel
that's got nothing to do with St Thomas
so any other yeah is there any teaching
from Saint Francis the
the very friends
oh
yeah I mean that's one of the cool
things about the franciscans is they
know where they came from they are
really devoted to the original core
values you know
it's you know each each uh religious
order or or Society has its particular
I'm going to be kind of silly with this
they're schtick right they're they're
thing that they're all about and with
the franciscans it it really is about
um you can say poverty and love you know
and poverty doesn't necessarily mean
like
owning nothing although you know
Franciscan friars don't own a hell of a
lot
uh and what what does that free you up
for well you can you know you can accept
alms and then give them to somebody else
who needs them more
um you can give of your time and your
energy and your attention and love to to
take care of people I mean even teaching
you know sometimes so going back in time
there have been religious orders where
maybe some of the people who were
belonging to them really didn't belong
in them uh and so some you know yet
people who are monks and nuns teaching
at different places and they'd get kind
of sour on their students but if you're
a genuine Franciscan you are going to be
a very loving person you know
um and then the third order which I
think is you know that's something else
that's really great about religious
orders you don't necessarily have to
like give everything up and
join a monastery or a friary or
something like that you can be in a
third order and practice that
spirituality in a more limited way but
still incorporating it so yeah I mean
and they do read
um you know bonaventrian and other
Franciscan literature to help them out
with that so
there is still a
significant
stamp of Saint Francis on on his order
which
you know
not always the case I mean I will say
this about the benedictines who I very
much love
um one of the benedictines who I'm
friends with pointed out that the
benedictines have gone through more
reforms than any other religious order
now why do you go through it before
because you've screwed up and you've
gotten corrupt for Generation after
generation and things have gone downhill
for you know maybe 100 years then you're
like we got to get our crap together you
know what was this order originally
about not like sitting in the monastery
and getting drunk all the time it's
about doing good things in the world you
know and so so the benedictines have
done quite a lot of that but I think the
franciscans have done that too and
they've you know they've also I should
mention this is long after bonaventure's
time they've had kind of spin-offs you
know so there's like
the main franciscans if you've ever
heard of the capuchins they're they're a
type of Franciscan right so you get this
with religious orders just like with the
benedictines the car the cistercians
spin off of them they're like yeah these
other benedictines they're not hardcore
enough we need to get our you know stuff
together so you know there's different
ways of living a Franciscan lifestyle
you notice that the franciscans have a
lot of hospitals here in the United
States right that that's a major
um
way of of living out the life of of
poverty and love I think for for quite a
few people
you know yeah
among pilgrims
some say that
he should travel with nothing because if
you you know do have a lot of
you know whatever yeah
the potential is there to become
preoccupied with defending yeah yeah you
know because you're on the road you know
oh yeah
yeah
I mean the you could think of it as like
the hardcore
we can't compromise at all on these
values as a matter of fact let's see if
we can get even poorer you know types
and the people who are like well you
know we're not going to totally
compromise but we need to be realistic
about this Somebody's gotta you know pay
the rent on the or pay for these houses
that we have people staying in and you
know how are you know we do need things
every once in a while but there's and
it's kind of funny because even the
um
the you know the more relaxed party
they're not like saying let's make as
much money as possible or you know uh
we're gonna have a pilgrimage and uh
we'll we'll line the the streets with
gold or something like that you know
um but you know they yeah you're right
they they there is this emphasis on the
part of the spirituals and saying no if
we're going to be committed to this we
got to be 100 committed to this idea of
poverty and so the question is really
how poor should you be right
um and it's a there's a real tension
there I think because what if you have
nothing
and then you get cut out in a terrible
storm you know and you take shelter and
you get sick and
um
nobody takes you in to take care of you
you know wouldn't it be good to
have some medicine along yeah but that's
a possession right or wouldn't it be
good to have like maybe a tent along
with you well
then you're tempted to like put your
tent somewhere and you're worried about
somebody stealing at her you know so
yeah it's a real it's a real issue
um any other questions or
comments
you look like you've got one brewing in
your head yeah I'm trying to put it
together
um he's a theologian I mean yeah he
obviously is the highest he believes in
the in the scriptures and why isn't that
just an end-all for him I mean be a
theological interpret them but why go to
philosophy and try to
uh see if you can make philosophy agree
with religion when you're already there
yeah so that's a that's a great question
and it's it's not one just for
Bonaventure but all of these guys right
uh and women because there's there's you
know women like Hildegard of Bingham who
are
studying philosophy as well or aloe East
Argan Toyota
wife of abelard
um
so the the easiest answer is to say that
scripture doesn't give you enough and
from the very beginning
in Christianity even before the
scriptures had been assembled into and
canonized as the Bible there were
thinkers who already had exposure to
philosophy many of them as part of an
education or rhetoric or these other
liberal arts and they realize that the
scriptures are great and they have to be
Central but they don't provide you with
enough for figuring out everything that
you need to figure out so you need to
use whatever cultural resources you have
and in
the the West it was called philosophy I
mean it's also medicine it's also
mathematics it's not as if they only
um used philosophy right so they they
did have this project of trying to take
things that often seem quite
incompatible with each other and figure
out how to bring them together uh
successfully and you notice they don't
always come up with the same
set of answers right they'll just like
you know Thomas saying yeah we we got to
believe on faith that um God created the
world it's not Eternal and then
Bonaventure is saying no no we can we
can argue for that you know they they
don't have exactly the same thing but
they're all the other thing you could
say is all of these thinkers these
Christian thinkers like Augustine or
Anselm or Bonaventure or Thomas or
boethius
they think that God gave us Minds to use
them not to
repress them
or say this is good enough but to know
and know know more and understand more
obviously you don't want to like Go off
into what they call a vice of curiosity
meaning like investigating crap that
doesn't have any use but people do that
with scriptural things I'll give you an
example when I used to teach at Indiana
State Prison I teach these religious
Studies classes and some of them were
New Testament or you know about the
canonical and non-canonical gospels and
I'd get these guys who'd get into
arguments in class and it would be about
um
a big thing between the Orthodox and the
Catholics
when it says in the scripture that Jesus
um they were talking about Jesus's
brothers or cousins because the word is
adolfos in Greek right and it can mean
either
does that mean that Mary and Joseph
after Jesus was born had kids together
which is what the Orthodox typically say
or that these were just his cousins and
who were they connected to we don't have
we don't actually know because Mary you
know after having Jesus didn't have sex
with Joseph and my answer to these these
people who are debating this was like
who the hell cares
nothing absolutely nothing of how you
live a good life or the meaning of any
other Christian thing depends on this
one point why are you quibbling about
this right and the answer there is
essentially the vice of curiosity right
they they wanted to focus on the things
that don't really matter and ignore you
know things like The Sermon on the Mount
right that's that's pretty important
that's pretty Central right you know if
you're focusing on this and not that
that's a problem right or if you're
thinking about like philosophy
you know if you're Thomas Aquinas or
Bonaventure and you're not thinking
about
um
you know virtues and vices moral
philosophy or about is the World created
or not can we prove there's a God or not
you know philosophy of religion or
metaphysics and you're focusing on some
tiny little minutia thing over here
you're not doing philosophy right for
them right so so it really has to do
with using our mind uh to the to the
extent possible did you have a hand up I
thought I saw
no
okay
well any other questions I don't want to
hold people over too long
um
satisfied intellectually with
yeah go ahead
do you know anything about like the
criteria that
like
a new order would have to oh
well the number one thing is that the
pope likes you right because you you
appeal to the to the pope and
um I mean
that's I mean it's a good question I was
being a little facetious but you have to
show that you're not just like
Reinventing the wheel that another order
is doing right that's part of it so that
there is a new it's called a new charism
because that's typically the word that's
that's used is is there
um that your way of life is a regular
way of life you're not using it as an
excuse to like
you know soak people for money or have
orgies or whatever it's going to be
um and they they generally want to see
some like staying power some continuity
you know but you notice like with the
timeline it's not long after Francis
begins Gathering his um his members and
living together as a community that
they're they're looking for recognition
and it comes in stages right you know
they don't just say all right you've
satisfied all of our criteria you're in
you're just as good as the benedictines
you know uh it takes it takes a while
and even after that right so
um the pope is given his approval it's a
it's an order but the people in the
University are like yeah we don't want
these bums in here who's giving them a
chair
[Music]
please go to the circulation desk to
apply everyone now my red cards cannot
be issued after 7 45 also be aware that
internet computers will be turned off
shortly thank you and have a great
evening
away
um good thing we're not using a computer
so yeah there's there's a bunch of
different stages but I mean it's kind of
the stuff that you'd expect right
um it's not like there's some form that
had to be filled out at the time or you
know I mean if it was done today there'd
probably be like forums involved I guess
um but there aren't there are
occasionally new I don't think there's
any new orders but every once in a while
like a new Society will get formed
within the Catholic Church
um
and I'm not sure what the criteria for
that are in the present but whatever
they are now I'm sure they weren't
that complex back then you know
any other questions yeah go ahead
the wandering aesthetic and yeah I mean
that's a common theme
and different religions right yeah yeah
if you know if there's like
communication I mean it's like Buddhists
yeah
Muslim sufis
right and then so
like around 100 200 I mean Jason who's
just been doing it
in the Middle East and I was just
curious
was it being done before oh yeah so was
this just sort of like a common
idea or inspiration that people felt
somehow closer to spirituality well
I mean you can be uh you can be
connected with God as a Benedictine and
staying in a stable monastery just as
well as you can be a Franciscan or
Dominican I think it's more like who's
attracted to what kind of
um there seems to be a universal oh yeah
yeah to to being
um to begging for alms wandering around
and it's not just um religious
the ancient cynics and the Greek cynics
did that as well
there's actually letters about how how
you should Beg by
um attributed to Kratos the third skull
art not actually buy it probably written
around 100 A.D or so
um yeah there's there's lots and there's
secular people doing it today you know
people
observe this thing they call minimalism
kind of tough to do in our society right
because we have mobile technology and
there's a lot of places that won't take
cash anymore
so I think it's getting a little bit
tougher to do
totally divesting yourself of everything
except for your clothes the staff maybe
a bag and wandering around but people
people do it and it it's it is kind of
dependent
so like if you think about Buddhism
Jainism uh Hinduism these these uh
dharmic uh Indian subcontinent religions
where there's a very big emphasis on uh
ascetics sometimes staying in
monasteries sometimes wandering
they're incredibly dependent on
householders as they're typically called
for their food even sometimes for their
clothing medical supplies that sort of
thing so there's a symbiotic
relationship usually and I think that
you can say the same thing existed for
them franciscans and the Dominicans and
yeah it's kind of a nice cross-cultural
across religious
thing
um
and you know a lot of those those people
who do that get involved in
intra-religious dialogue you know
so yeah
I mean it's it's you could say it's one
recognized as legitimate but also
sometimes looked out upon my
co-religionist Motif right that shows up
over and over again yeah
yeah
any other questions comments
well thanks for your questions and your
attention and I hope that you you know
enjoyed this you'll come back for the
other ones that we've got coming up in
August and then November right uh always
the
first Wednesday of the month we'll be
looking at a
modern thinker and then a late modern
thinker
so yeah thanks I'll uh see you all
around